hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast
and I'm just checking in on you checking
in to see how you're doing seeing how
you're
feeling um sorry I'm way behind this
week I
uh got some family in town family B Eed
and uh I didn't do the podcast last
night and this morning
I had to do the Rich Eisen show one of
my favorite favorite shows to do
transcend Sports just a [__] great
guy uh went down there and had a great
time so um I think it's live I'm not
sure [__] it we'll do it live I think
it's live so I don't know if it already
happened or
not I think it did I think it already
happened whatever we had a great
discussion we talked about you know
people talking about firing Bill bich we
talked about the Michigan thing we
talked about old dads I could finally
talk about old dads I I I [__] sat in
traffic I mean I had a whole goddamn day
here I got to get back to the gym I'm
eating right but I got to get back to
the gym I swear to god dude I like I
understand why guys my age are just
doing this [__] you know it's like you
know the testosterone right the hair
plugs the the botox the penis
enlargement the calf
implants right the horse tranquilizers I
understand you know the the the micro
doing I get it I get it if you just
[__] naturally live out your life
whatever that means you don't you don't
take any supplements or anything like
that you know I watch these Lions take
down an elephant one
time and that's what life is life is the
Lions and you're the [__]
elephant he was able to Shake him off
for a while when he was young but then
it was [__] thing was old and it just
happens one time that last lion jumps on
you and your two back knees buckle and
you go
down your back legs buckle and that's
just [__] it the thing just goes down
and and just
never and your [__] come on man get
up you know and it thing just doesn't
[__] get up and like that's what it
is if I don't go to the gym and I don't
eat right and I don't stretch within
like a week and a half
period like
um I just I just become I come become
Billy oldf face and I have to tell you
that my mobility and my strength as a 55
year old man versus 55y old men when I
was a kid like we got to admit human
beings are [__] crushing it for a
long long there was no chicks that were
[__] in their
50s
when I was a kid well into their 40s
they were
[__] they weren't even over the hill
they they were the
Horizon it was [__] over they laid in
the sun they smoked [__] cigarettes
they drank booze I mean they literally
look like Robert
Shaw in [__] Jaws by the with even
with the sideburns too by the time they
were like [__] 48 it was a WAP and
you know you look at some of that [__]
like look at I just was looking the
other day somebody put this up on
Instagram when you watched All in the
Family they look like they were 70 they
were in their [__]
40s so I don't know what to tell you so
anyway yeah I start Aging in Carol o'
Conor
years so
um you know I did so well when I was in
New York but as you if you knew from the
last podcast I tried an egg cream so you
know once I did that I took a hit of the
crack pipe but I've just i' I've been
able to to to not relapse on the
desserts you know I've seen them I've
been in the vicinity I'm looking at them
they're looking at me oh for God [__]
sakes what do you
want um what do you want what the person
call me and then not call me what is
going on hang on a
second you know God bless these [__]
people that try to do something in the
neighborhood I just picked P up the
phone and the person just goes hi
hi I'm I'm Patty something or other you
know um D is this a good time to talk I
said no I'm doing a podcast but have a
great day patty patty cake patty cake oh
patty patty cake patty
cake stop knocking on the
doors that's a [__] thankless job
just walking around doing that [__] what
was I talking about I was talking about
the God damn egg cream no I've been able
to [__] look at these desserts and
they're looking back at me you know what
I mean like I'm looking across at Mike
single ter and his eyes are getting all
wide like he's going to come in and [__]
me up and I'm able to do the Dan Marino
quick release and get the [__] away from
it and um all it takes is
like you know if you just dipped back
into sugar again and you just did one
thing all it takes is like a day and a
half and it's gone if you've been on the
sugar if you're using if you're avoiding
your friends and your loved ones and
you're just locking yourself in a closet
consuming a [__] you know timon's
cake yourself then you know it's going
to take longer but at least I got that
out of my [__]
life but um
anyway I watched a little football the
other night the uh Buffalo Bills versus
the uh Denver Broncos me and Paul verie
we picked the Monday night special on
bed MGM and uh
I you know I watched that [__] game
like I can't figure out like I felt like
both Josh
Allen and
uh Russell were were like they were just
they they're just like in their heads
they were making throws that they don't
normally make it was kind of like a
weird
thing um didn't understand why that was
happening uh and I still can't believe
like how the [__] is Buffalo a five and
five team they were like stacked they
were loaded what is going on the whole
[__] AFC East is just it's just in
shambles then the Dolphins came roaring
out yeah the Dolphins are going to do
then they've been [__] in the bed and
now for whatever [__] reason the
Raiders are going down to Miami and
they're like they're like [__] the
Dolphins are favored by like I don't
know 62 points or
something I guess cuz they have that
backup quarterback the backup to the
backup to the backup like the
Giants I don't know this is a weird time
of year people start getting [__]
hurt people start getting fired right
people start eat drinking egg creams and
what happens it all goes to [__]
[__] um anyway I had one of my uh
buddies came to town and I went down to
The Comedy Store last night to do a
benefit and I had this new idea that I
wanted to do and I was like you know
what [__] this I'm going to open with
this thing and just see where this goes
and it went absolutely Ely perfectly and
of course I didn't record it cuz I never
record and then I started mumbling it to
myself when I got home and I was already
[__] it up and I was just like why
why why why wouldn't you just record it
just to that first time just to have it
when you're speaking from the hat right
and you're not thinking about why isn't
this working like it did the other night
or how did I say it last night you're
just [__] there you're there and the
crowd is there there like those [__]
cookies downstairs that my wife keeps
buying you know cuz she likes something
sweet every once in a while and I just
say can you get this [__] out of the
it's not fair it's not fair to live with
somebody and tell them to get all the
cookies and chips out of the house you
know they have to live like this this
this All or Nothing lifestyle because
you don't know how to [__] control
your
impulses you
know Nia can have some chips and then
leave she you know what she can walk
away she can [__] make a little money
in blackjack and go back to the [__]
we not
me I'm I'm [__] I'm I'm staying at
the
table all right splitting
Oreos sorry splitting Orioles like Aces
you get it everybody I'll be in
Vegas this Friday night oh my God
listening to these [__] people
whining about this goddamn race I'm
going to call it right now
despite all the boo Birds this is going
to be the best visual [__] race in
recent F1 history um with all of those
[__] casinos because you know
something as much as the one that I love
even though it's usually a boring race
cuz the cars are so [__] wide you
can't pass is I love the one um in uh
Monaco you know what I mean that was
like the like Monaco you just heard
about that when I was a kid this is
before the internet
so you'd watch like a James Bond movie
you know and he would be there with his
white tuxedo and his [__] black
tie just with a just an stunning piece
of ass next to him and that's really
what she was you know what I mean there
was no [__] relationship she was just
there to hang out with the coolest guy
in the planet and then get banged
afterwards and she was happy you know
there was no Facebook to whine about you
know that he [__] I don't know what
he did you know he he
[__] wrapped up in a ridle riddle
with the Enigma of how he got her to go
into bed with him or whatever it was
like
no she saw a guy pull up in an Austin
Martin whatever the [__] he had that
silver [__] car okay she saw the
Bulge and I'm not talking about his dick
I'm talking about the gun all right
she's like this is a dangerous
man all right and then he goes in there
he's totally chill he tells people how
he likes his drink and the way he wants
his name set so now she's on his arm
right and he's [__] winning cuz what
else would he be doing you knew this guy
was going to win she saw a winner you
know what she wanted some of that for
herself and she would go back and bang
this guy that was my idea of what Monaco
was you know but whenever you go to see
the race you know they just show the
[__] tracks you know they don't they
don't go to the
casinos and see all of these people that
saw that James Bond movie or whatever
[__] movie I
saw you know they don't show those
people trying to recreate
it you know by having children dig
diamonds out of a mind I mean it's not a
movie anymore I mean there's only a
certain way you can get this money
okay in a movie it's clean energy in
reality it's it's it's it's definitely
it's definitely [__] something
else so anyway
um yeah that was the Monaco that I knew
and and like that's the only thing when
I watched that race I just wish that
there was
more of those shots of Monaco CU I'm
[__] fascinated it's not I always
thought it was part of France it isn't
it's a sovereign
state you know like San
Marino
Monaco sorry I got a phone call and look
who walked in hello it's the lovely Nia
it's me I was just talking to them about
how cool I think this race is going to
be at F1 oh yeah because it's going to
be at night like they do it in [__]
Singapore
Singapore Rob to the rich and give it to
the Singapore are you just starting your
podcast I'll I'll I'll step out if
you're doing your thing I'm doing my
thing it's I'm like 12 minutes in okay
all righty all righty all right nice to
see you nice to see you too nice to see
everybody not really but you know to
hear everybody um anyway so um I the
long the long and the short of this
is
um I just you know Vegas I mean what
it's it's [__] chis they know what
they're going to do they're going to
show off the
Gams right they're going to show off the
ladies they they're going to have all of
those [__] casinos lit up you got to
watch even if you don't give a [__] it's
going to be at night it's going to be so
cool and just to have that whole thing
[__] lit up I hope it's a huge
success you know what's funny they
already said that the the race has made
more money it's made two times the
amount of money that the Super Bowl's
going to bring in and what I think is
hilarious about that is just like well
for who not for the average
Joe some guy living on [__] uh hard
luck Lane out there right next you know
on the corner of hard luck and crapped
out right is he going to get a [__]
check cuz the F1 went there well it's
going to create jobs going to trickle
down
um I'm hoping it's going to be a great
uh a a a smashing success because what
I'm hoping is is that maybe uh Moto GP
comes there the next year and then we
could have two
races in the Americas the United States
of the Americas um personally that's
just my own selfish way of looking at
this oh by the way I will be doing a
show um Friday
night and uh you know meeting a bunch of
my old knucklehead friends from back in
the day old Billy boy pre- comedy and uh
we're going to do we always do we're
going to [__] hang out we're going to
have some drinks you know I don't drink
what am I going to have I have an Arnold
Palmer that's what the [__] I order I'll
order that at night like a [__] idiot
you know what I mean it's so stupid I
what what am I going to do you know I'm
just you know what it is I used up all
my fun days I know I've said this before
but God damn it I'm going to say it
again if you if I can give you any
[__] advice as a younger person is go
easy I mean have fun when you're young
but go go go
easy you know you're already going to
have to cut some [__] out when you get
older but like to cut it all
out the cookies the soda the potato
chips it's like what what I don't even
know if there's even any fun in my life
anymore I just literally said that cuz
Nia was walking
in
we have fun all the time what are you
talking about I'm talking about how you
know I'm at this age now where you know
I didn't go to the gym when I was in New
York we were running around doing all of
this stuff having a good time and like
just not going for like four five days I
was comparing it to like when you see a
pride of lions take down an elephant and
you're just rooting for the elephant the
elephant's you and you know when your
back legs collapse then that's just it
and you just see the trunk go up there
is nothing sadder in the [__] world
than seeing an elephant get killed by a
pride Alliance God when did you see this
you see but you used to watch all those
weird animal attacks videos on YouTube
you were in a in a phase for a while
where you were just watching animals
like brutalize each other well yeah I'm
I'm fascinated with the whole thing and
then it makes and then it makes me think
about God like this is the only way that
they can get sustenance is you had to
create these [__] goddamn vampires
with four
legs okay and then they go up to these
guys guys that have teeth like us that
kind of just gnawing on a branch and
it's just like their their whole purpose
in life is that they're food and they're
going to be eaten alive who purpose pray
oh well I mean but they're part of the
whole like the circle of life man I know
but like they're like God loves you God
loves everybody and he does all this
stuff and he makes people like that yeah
he makes like sociopaths and then he
just makes people kind of going down to
the drinking water who are [__]
honest and they get [__] ripped apart
and it's just like what is he doing what
is he waiting for yeah when is uh old
Junior coming
back junior you're talking about Jesus
oh yeah hey Seuss if you're in a
different part of the world right yeah
what what the what is he waiting
for this is getting too deep yeah well
you're in a very like you know
contemplative like I feel like a is that
a word yes contemplative is a word
contemplative no contemplative is it
ttis or tetanus
what is it tonius or tetanus those are
two different things you can have tonius
or you get a tetanus shot there two
different bille oh no but some people
well the way they say tontis it sounds
like Alex Alex are we going we going
down that path again oh Jesus Oh Billy
trying to pronounce things over here Jes
no you've been having like a very sort
of existential sort of like spiritual
questioning you know the last year
especially I feel like oh yeah you're
asking you're asking all the questions
man oh is it annoying you no no no no I
just I'm I'm I'm watching you go on this
journey these different things seem to
happen and it makes you like why does
this happen why is this allowed to
happen and I'm just picturing you over
in the corner just let him work through
it just let him work through it that's
pretty much My Philosophy when it comes
to you now now after 20 years of being
together I'm just like just let them
work through it just let him work
through it I was actually thinking about
something that like you mentioned
recently and I was like you know I'm
just going to let him work through that
you had your opinion about it so I'm
just going to let you like work I have
my opinion about it but I let you work
through it you know all right yeah I
appreciate that yeah thank you I mean
you're welcome all right I do that with
you too yeah what do you mean you know
you just get all [__]
going I get going me it's like fishing I
just let you [__] tie yourself out
and then I gradually bring you back to
the boat it's going to be okay ni let's
just stick you in the [__] ice chest
here have you cool off and we'll uh
we'll work it out yeah yeah yeah we've
been having some really good arguments
lately yeah it only gets to medium heat
and then we like what the [__] are we I
don't want to argue then weing it back
what are you trying to do here what am I
trying to do here and then that's it no
we've been having a great time I've been
having a great time with you it's life
is life you know well if you know it's
good for you you'll keep that going all
right oh really if you know what's good
for you you'll keep that going Hey
listen don't threaten me during the
[__] holiday season all right I'll
take all these decorations and walk oh
please all right get out of here let me
finish this [__] thing oh are you
kicking me out now well I don't know
what you're doing here you're like half
here half not all right all right I'm
out of here how did Rich Eisen go oh it
went great Nia thank you for asking that
mean Rich you want to be out of here how
did Rich Eisen go I'm sure you am great
I I love that guy I love that guy you
know my favorite thing about about him
is when you go into the Green Room he's
got these pictures of him with his kid
you can just tell he's an awesome dad oh
that's nice not to mention on his desk
it says greatest dad
ever in case you were wondering no but I
always looked at that I'm like I know
one of his kids gave him that for like
father's you can tell right right you
can tell you know what I mean like when
you go into somebody's [__] office
that's successful and all it is is their
Awards and like pictures of them with
other people standing there with those
big faces and the [__] tuxedos you're
like all right then you go like that
guy's been [__] doing this for almost
30 years wildly successful and you go in
he's got pictures of him and his kids I
think that's really nice that's sweet
yeah you know it's called it's called
[__] uh knowing what's important
that's right all right which brings me
back to you if you know what was
important you go downstairs and make me
a [__] sandwich don't make me ask you
Jesus with the sandwich already I
offered to make you a sandwich last
night you didn't want it oh cuz it was
late at night I definitely wanted one
you did but you you know what I'm back
to what I'm back to the handful of raw
cashews in a glass a glass of water it
totally fills you up though no that's
the way to go I should night when I
wanted tacos you you said to me have a
handful of cashews and some water and
you'll be psyched and I didn't do that I
went psyched you with the it wasn't that
good that's the thing well I was going
to go to a taco truck with the real
[__] people making it and instead
where I went was they weren't there
anymore and then for the first time in
my [__]
life I uh I went to a Del Taco I've
never been to one I was never a Taco
Bell guy Taco Bell for me Taco Bell over
for me Taco Bell over Del Taco although
apparently Del Taco has great
cheeseburgers but I would never think to
get a cheeseburger from Del Taco but I
prefer Taco Bell over Del Taco just
because of how they season the meat I
just feel like they're out of ideas at
Taco Bell and they just keep doing this
incestuous thing with with with with
Mexican Cuisine yeah they just
completely this is this is a Gort Daka
burrito whatever the [__] they're doing
over there it's always like a yeah a
tortilla wrapped inside it's Nazi doctor
[__] let's sew a [__] Taco to a
burrito and stick it in a [__]
Empanada and then put some cilantro on
top of it and give it a name that ends
in a [__] sort of's Mexican sounding
name right right it's not even like a
real thing it's kind of like that it's
like the turd duckin you know when
people put the the the chicken and a
turkey and a duck together you should IM
immediately be on a serial killer watch
list if you have yeah I agree it's too
much why are you doing all that it's
just no but it's it's it's the
combining of of different species and
sewing them together and then [__] Co
I saw that French chef that one time was
doing something like that and he
actually stepped back and he looked at
it what he was doing and then he just
and he had three Michelin stars at his
place and he just walked away from all
of it went totally veggie and then came
back and got three stars again I mean
that guy's one of the baddest dudes ever
that I can't remember his name I'm going
go you talking about Daniel whom from 11
Madison Park no I'm talking about jacqu
Pierre
franois from San Marino via the Vatican
all if you had to go to any Sovereign
City what does sovereign mean free I
think what it really means is we don't
pay taxes we've made so much money we're
not even in a country anymore what
options do I have Russian
[__] being paid in Gold being paid in
Gold I don't know what happens at these
places so what are you asking me well
I'm not asking it like that to have that
kind of a [__] response no I just
don't understand what you mean if you
had to go to any sovereign state where
would you want to go sovereign state not
city state but I don't know what those
sovereign states Monaco San Marino the
Vatican Marblehead a lot of people don't
know Marblehead Massachusetts I was
going to say Massachusetts no Mar
Marblehead is a sovereign state they are
not governed by At All by the rules of
Massachusetts really yeah they had so it
goes back to the king of England I don't
know I've never [__] with you it's
yeah I was going to say that doesn't
make any sense I I don't know any of
those places like that so I don't know
Monaco seems pretty sexy glitzy and
glamorous doesn't it now what do you
what do you base that on cuz me it was
James Bond yeah it's anything that's
been in
movies it's the Bad Bunny song and video
accompaniment you know I don't know I
don't know Bad Bunny behave isn't that
where one of your races that you like
isn't F1 in Monaco y yeah it's not as
exciting cuz the cars are so wide
there's barely any passing yeah and I
just wish that they would show and I
used to always think that those were all
rich people on their Yachts but it isn't
there's a bunch of [__] like me
that bought tickets to sit on somebody's
yacht and be like can you believe we're
on a
yacht is the cars go by which I would
totally do I was going to say can we do
that though cuz that sounds fabulous it
is but until you realize this it's like
sitting in Grand stands but you're on a
boat Grand stands oh like in the in like
yeah like you're sitting it's like the
bleachers but you're on a yach that's
how much money that's how much money
Monaco has that their bleachers are run
like a yacht amazing but I still think
the but I think the to just sort of take
in the city then you'd be able to see
more of the city but they kind of go
around that corner and go right into the
tunnel so then you can't really see them
so then you're kind of hoping somebody
goes over the [__] side like that one
guy did in the open carpet my
God that was racing the [__] the
[__] car was like oh that was racing
yeah it was like 3 feet off the ground
the [__] front end's lifting up and
the guy just loses traction and just
[__] goes is he okay okay no he died
oh my God bill yeah you don't [__]
you can't you couldn't drive a a 19
[__] 59 anything anything you
couldn't drive a 1959 anything and go 70
M an hour off a cliff into some [__]
water a well rest in peace to that man
that's terrible rest in pie I think what
it really was I'm [__] I don't know
if he died I've Just Seen well look
there's a video of it okay maybe we
should check and see if he made it I
think he died no I have total respect
for the guy okay you know what I always
picture is just his
eyes all [__] wide behind the goles
mobra okay let's let's let's let's let's
move on oh we talked about we talked
about that how people want to stay in
hotel rooms where people died oh yeah
and I just like what in the [__]
that's you though you talk about you
were talking about a hotel that you
wanted to say in that somebody died at
and I was saying how it creeped me out
no no no yes yes yes no it just happens
they just redid the hotel I want to stay
at the hotel and I looked up what room
it happened in and said I want to stay
in any room but that room first of all
people have died in every [__] hotel
the amount of hotel rooms that you've
probably been in where they had to cut
up the carpet and lay down some new [__]
because of what happened I know I have I
stayed in so many [__] motels oh yeah
definitely 100% 100% [__] happened in
there but the thing is you don't know it
the thing about it is is knowing it and
going there just don't get the the the
that light what's that light the black
light black light don't get the black
light going I've you know I've gone I've
gone to the light aisle in every [__]
hardware store I've never seen a black
light I don't understand what a black
light is it's light but it's black yeah
it's it's like two different things man
it's like Velvet Revolver it's hot and
it's soft I'll get you one for Christmas
and you can take it on the road with you
you can check all your your hotel rooms
before you go in there I don't think you
want to do that that but you know you
know what's funny about me it wouldn't
even bother me it wouldn't no why cuz I
would just look at it logically like
I've been laying in this filth my entire
life and nothing bad has happened right
right right I don't walk out I don't
walk out and people go you got somebody
else's jizz on you nobody can see
it now I wouldn't go to a
nightclub you wouldn't go to a nightclub
I wouldn't go to nightclub after laying
in in a [__] hotel room
right wait what you wouldn't go to a
nightclub yeah cuz they always have
those [__] lights where all the all
the lint and everything show up on you I
see mean you know when you if you wore
the wrong shirt you threw a towel in
with your shirt and it's like no you're
not getting any [__]
tonight game show
over exactly all right there pockets all
right I'll see you later I'll see you
later I'm I'm going to dip out now it
was nice talking I was going to say nice
being on the podcast yeah all right all
right all right then take it easy okay
no no reason to be [__]
hostile um all right let me do the uh
the reads here for the week for the week
for the week for the week um we a k for
the week meaning me all right let's look
up freckled balls. org at AOL.com there
it is all right um live reads 1116 oh
look who it is everybody it's simply
safe you know there's never a wrong time
to protect your home but this fall
happens to be an especially good time
what are they let somebody out it's
[__] ominous because you can oh
because you can get up to 50% off on a
brand new Simply Safe home security
system all right everybody's still
locked up it was named the best home
security of 2023 by US News and World
Report Simply Safe as a comprehensive
protection is comprehensive protection
for the whole
home with Advanced senses that the tech
break-ins fires floods and more Plus HD
cameras for both inside and out it's
powered by 247 professional monitoring
for less than a dollar a day half the
cost of traditional home security with
new 24/7 live guard protection and the
Smart Alarm Wireless indoor camera
monitoring agents can see and speak to
Intruders can I please get video of that
you thought you were pretty smart didn't
you you weren't expecting Simply
Safe they got to have the other thing
like once you start talking to them when
they're in their house they then you
lock all the [__] doors and then
they're trapped like a rat uh I've seen
some of those videos uh helping stop
crime in real time a powerful technology
exclusively from Simply Safe yeah like
you take the [__] door handles off on
the inside if you've seen some
businesses do that it's [__] amazing
and then the guy's just freaking out
then what's great is by the time the
cops get there the burglar is so tired
from trying to kick open the door or
climb the [__] walls it's an easy
cuff for him uh satisfaction is backed
by simply saves money back guarantee try
Simply Save for 60 days risk-free if you
don't love it return your system for a
full
refund dy I like you like um one of the
greatest lines ever delivered in a movie
rest in peace Paul Rubin uh for a
limited time listeners can get a special
50% off any simplysafe system with a
fast protect plan visit simplysafe
docomomo safe like Simply Safe ah [__]
there's another one I thought I was done
oh coincidentally it's Helix everybody
Helix you know it's Helix sleep the
Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses
including the award-winning Lux colle
collection the newly released Helix
Elite collection and a mattress designed
for Big and Tall sleepers and even a
mattress made just for kids so how will
you know what about people who [__] the
bed do they got something for that how
will you
know and I don't mean literally I mean
figuratively you had a big meeting you
forgot what you were going to say and
you just [__] the bed you didn't make
any money like maybe they have something
that sort of cradles you you know and
they have a helix hand to rub your
forehead to tell you it's going to be
okay all right that's a different
mattress anyway so how will you know
which Helix mattress works best for you
and your body take the Helix sleep quiz
and find your perfect mattress in under
2 minutes models with memory foam layers
to provide optimal pressure relief in
your sleep on your if you sleep on on
your side sorry models with a more
responsive foam to cradle your body
there it is for essential support in the
stomach and back sleeping positions plus
enhance cooling features to keep you
from overheating at night you know what
they should do they should make like a
the foam be like how you are on your
back and then if you roll to your left
it's just like an an imprint of your
left and then an imprint of your right
and it looks like that you you know and
just throughout the night you can just
kind of do
that am I nuts and then all the way on
the other side is laying on your
stomach this is what Steve Jobs did he
would just say [__] like that and then
other people invented it then he got the
[__] credit uh plus enhanced cooling
features to keep you from overheating at
night and if and if you if your spine
needs some extra TLC they got you every
Helix mattress has a hybrid design
combining individually wrapped steel Co
coils in the base with premium foam
layers on top it's the perfect
combination of comfort and support don't
want to take my word for it Helix has
been awarded the number one mattress
picked by GQ and Wired Magazine it is
even recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine as a go-to solution solution
solution solution Helix for um improving
your sleep Helix is offering 25% off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
your listeners uh for our listeners in
honor of Black
Friday well let me
give do yourself a favor if you're go to
one of those Black Friday event wrap
those two [__] pillows around your
goddamn head so you come out of there
alive uh go to helixsleep.com bur and
use the code Helix Partners partner 25 h
e Li iix p a r t n r25 h e l iix p a r t
n e
r25 that was a different time signature
uh is th this is their best offer yet
and it won't last long
with Helix better sleep starts now all
right and that is the podcast we have a
bonus half hour special of the Monday
morning of of the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast have a great weekend you
[Music]
com hey what's going on it's Bill Burr
and it's time for the Monday Morning
podcast from Monday November 16th 2015
what's going on how are you how are you
blah blah blah and all of that
[__] um I am back out here in Los
Angeles and guess what old freckles is
on
vacation that's right I did my last gig
of the
year my last Road gig I should say let
be drinking tea on this one cuz my
[__] voice is shot as you can hear
after uh my past weekend but I'm I don't
have any more [__] road gigs I don't
got any more [__] to do I think I do
have to go back to New York to promote F
is for family by the way which is coming
out on Netflix December
18th the same day that they're releasing
[__] Star
Wars oh my god dude I want to go see
it's a prequel you can look at a little
cute chewbaca see him when he was only
[__] a puppy
right is that what they do whatever so
we're competing against Star Wars or
whatever so I need you guys to please I
I tweeted out the uh the trailer for it
I need you guys to uh if you're ever
going to be there for me which I like to
think you are all the time I like to
think you
care um if you guys could retweet the uh
the trailer show it to as many people as
you
possible all ages all Races all Sexes
transgenders anybody just get people to
watch this [__] show uh cuz I think
it's really funny and I think you guys
are uh you know if you like this [__]
you're going to like that [__] you know
there you go whatever so uh that comes
out December 18th that's the big thing
uh I got coming up so but other than
that I don't I don't got [__] to do I
don't got [__] to do I just got back
from the airport LAX I immediately came
in here to do the podcast and uh the
second this is over I'm going downstairs
I'm taking a shower and I'm putting on
pajamas and I'm not taking them off
until [__] Thanksgiving I think
that's the next time I'm actually have
to be required to wear [__] clothes
you know so sort of respectable clothes
you know I can't have you [__]
uh just my my dad used to walk around in
his underwear all the [__] time was
just totally acceptable tidy White's in
a t-shirt you have a dad like that he
had no chill out clothes my dad was a
suit and he would just come home just
take his suit off and then would be
walking around with his dark dressed
socks on and his tidy what he always
just walked around my whole [__] it
was just completely [__]
normal in fact remember the only time
you ever put on pajamas was when he was
sick and it looked
weird um but anyways I was saying the
second this is over that's it I'm
jumping in the shower and I'm putting on
my [__]
PJs and I'm going to watch a bunch of
Bruins games that I taped I'm so [__]
happy right now um with the whole way
this weekend went Madison Square
Garden from the bottom of my heart if
you were one of the many people that
came out that night that was the single
greatest moment of my standup career I I
can't even put it into words I can't
believe that it
happened um I just from the second I got
on stage to the second it ended I did
like 90 minutes I went on stage right
and before I went on stage I was like
what time do I have to be off and they
were like you can't go past 10:30 cuz
then the union kicks in and then I don't
make any [__] money right so I to you
know I went on stage a little before
9:00 and I got off at like 10:28 I just
I think I said at one point to the crowd
that I I didn't want to get off and uh
they fortunately applauded and then I
just kept going and um I did every joke
that I could think of and it was [__]
amazing my apologies though I do have to
apologize to uh the people that were up
to my right I thought they were drunk
yelling at me what they were yelling was
that they couldn't hear there was
evidently a couple of pockets during
verie and d roza uh um I felt bad for
ver cuz he thought they were hackling
him and stuff and it kind of messed up
his set a little bit but he still killed
but um I thought they were just drunk I
was like oh this a bunch of yahoos who
got a box and now they're going to be
screaming at setups but they were
actually yelling that they couldn't hear
so from what I heard 10 minutes into my
ACT they fixed it and uh so you heard
the last hour and 20 so my apologies I
feel real bad about that um I don't know
why that
happened um but
anyways uh I'll take take you through
the whole day or how would I take you
through you know I I checked in on
checked in on you on Thursday Friday the
day before Madison Square Garden all
right
[Music]
um I went down to uh the stand to go do
a spot and I went up there and I [__]
around trying out this new material [__]
that I didn't do at Madison Square
Garden and you know went well and
everything and one of the owners over
there was was telling me to [__] um
make sure I enjoy Madison Square Garden
and blah blah blah and all this type of
[__] and the whole [__] time I was
downplaying Madison Square Garden um and
the reality was cuz I had to cuz it's
[__] Madison Square Garden if I
actually thought about the magnitude of
it I don't know what would have happened
so I just kept downplaying it and
everything and um so I I did a spot
there and then later on after I I did a
spot at standup New York sorry the stand
showing my age there I walked over to
the grammar SE where they had the
goddamn Comedy
Jam um so I'm drinking my [__] tea
here and uh I went over there and it was
the best Comedy Jam show that I've seen
to date um Josh and all the guys had
been on the road doing the show so the
band was sounded the best I ever heard
him sound um I got to do a sound check
there during the day and you just feel
some I'm telling you some um venues just
have the magic and you walked in you're
like this is going to be a sick show and
Josh and all the guys were excited going
dude there's going to be no chairs
everyone's going to be standing up
there's going to be 600 people in here
[__] packed so um so anyway so we
were going to close out the show doing
paradise city um because you it's a
great [__] Anthem to end the show
with and also what's his face Josh was
going dude and that's your funniest
[__] costume like that blonde wig
looks [__] ridiculous so I'm like all
right cool we'll do that so um everybody
went on and killed Matteo Lane crushed
it singing that uh Whitney Houston song
I Will Always Love You Right crushed it
then Eliza Schlesinger went up there she
[__] killed it um then I saw Big Jay
oakerson who's one of my favorite Comics
absolutely love the guy he sang that
song is it Weezer Say It Ain't So and he
was so [__] relaxed and so
comfortable and big Jay can actually
sing he was crushing it and the whole
[__] room was singing along with him
and I'm going look at the why how how
was he that [__] comfortable doing
that [__] he's just killing it and uh I
was thinking maybe because you know he
opened up for all these bands like he
opened up for corn Insane Clown posy so
those could to be really hostile crowds
he knew how to handle them so I'm
thinking well maybe he's just like this
is a layup these people actually want me
to hear it so he was walking around like
it was no big deal but was funny the
second he got off stage he turned into a
little kid he was just like dude that's
like the coolest thing I ever
did he crushed it then hanal burus came
in and Sayang Benny and the Jets and by
the way everybody does standup
beforehand you got to check the show out
you know does all their best [__] talks
about going to shows so makes the crowd
laugh they get great standup and then
you get to make watch him uh you know
act like an idiot in front of a band and
then um I went on in the end and did uh
um Paradise City
and it was just uh yeah it's just so it
was just it was [__] sick it was just
such a great environment there and
everyone was standing up and um and it's
also always [__] hilarious to walk
out you know dressed up as a you know
have a [__] wig on and [__] and then
just go into my act you know talking
about people that I think are [__] up
as I'm standing there wearing this
stupid wig and a leather
vest so we ended up having a great time
the drum were tuned up [__] just
sounded amazing so
um then ended up hanging out with
bartnik and we ended up in this Irish
Pub just me and him and uh and the
bartender and we ordered like one beer
and in the course of doing you know
sipping on the beer we all did like
three shots and then another shot with
the bartender we just had the best
[__] time just that New York [__] all
of a sudden it's 3:00 in the morning you
go into a deli you get a bacon egg and
cheese all this [__] you shouldn't be
[__] eating and we went back to my
apartment and just sat there uh you know
talking about how we were going to be at
the Garden the next day so
um anyway so the next day comes and now
here it is and I'm still downplaying it
going like I'm not even [__] excited
for this maybe I over downplayed this
[__] thing so as I mentioned during
the day I was going to have them uh I
rented a drum kit and I loaded it into
uh they had them loaded into [__]
Madison Square Garden the goddamn Comedy
Jam guys came over and we played for an
hour and a half in an empty Madison
Square Garden was like my manager my
agent my father-in-law was there my
publicist couple other people that was
it and
uh and Ben
Bailey who I knew played guitar and had
a studio and everything I actually
texted him a few days earlier I said hey
Ben I'm in New York and we've been
trying to get together in Jam for
[__] like 5 years I said hey man do
you want to uh can you play on Saturday
and he goes yeah man he goes I just
finished my studio at my house you got
to come by and I just wrote Back N I got
a better place he writes back like what
the
[__] I can't even see my place how do
you know it's better so I said you want
to [__] you know go to Madison Square
Garden he [__] freaked out so we got
a set list together on all that [__]
obvious obviously all the [__] that I
did with the Comedy Jam guys we had that
down and Ben Bailey's like a [__]
Black Sabbath
freak so we learned War Pigs and we were
supposed to learn one other I don't know
we ever got got to it but um so we ended
up going in there right and there was
all these guys setting up chairs and
[__] for the show that night I was like
oh man I don't want to sit up here and
making all this noise you
know [__] ruining this therea I go
when are they going to be done setting
up the chair so bug I'm they ah no no
they're used to it they're used to it go
ahead and get up there and play and um
we started playing it was [__]
unbelievable and the people working
there actually got into it they thought
it was cool that we were doing it cuz
they know we were just geeking out and
they started they started turning on the
lights you know doing like a light show
as we were playing in an empty [__]
Madison Square Garden and by the end of
it they uh they had the video guy comes
down and he starts filming us so I guess
on the last song we were up on the jumbo
Trum I think we closed with Paradise
City again but we did like custard pie
we did War Pigs Welcome to the Jungle Dr
Feelgood uh my publist also played drums
he went up there they did wanted Dead or
Alive just all this Arena Rock [__] my
agent went up there had a drag him up
there he ke went up and he
played um I and I'm going to post some
of these pictures too that that uh that
we had a photographer who was going to
be there for that night he posted them
and we had the best [__] time and I
really think that it helped me for my
show that night cuz I kind of went in
there and got a feel for the room got my
stink in there a little bit you know and
[Music]
um just got on the train went back to my
apartment and Neo was getting ready and
I was just sitting there as I was
waiting for her to get ready and I was
uh I was drinking a Budweiser right and
I never drink before shows ever I don't
give a [__] how far ahead it is right so
she just goes you having a beer and I
was like yeah
she goes you never drank before shows I
was like no no I don't just felt like
having one she goes are you nervous and
I was like
No And I don't know why I don't know why
just I wasn't nervous I should have been
but I wasn't and I went down to the
arena and everybody was there had a
bunch of people in the dressing room
hanging out talking almost right up till
we went on usually I'm like get the [__]
out of here for the last 10 minutes let
me be alone with my thoughts I just you
know what it was I did was two weeks on
to uh um through the Midwest and then I
did that run through Pennsylvania and
down in Florida so I was just I was on
my game and um I just felt like it was
going to be a good time so so the moment
of truth comes right verie shows up of
course you know wearing his sweater and
his [__] Jordans or whatever the [__]
he had I forget what he had Air Max D
roza showed up with wearing this [__]
hipster old lady swe sweater which I
actually made fun of when I got on stage
so Joe bartnik goes out and uh he does
the voice of God you know I got the
video for that I'm going to post that
too um it was [__] hilarious watching
he got people so [__] amped up right
so verie goes up he does his thing D
roza does his thing and then they uh and
then we showed the trailer for the first
time ever we showed the f is for family
trailer um which I literally had to walk
into the tunnel and blocked my ears
because I I didn't want to handle if
they weren't liking it so after it was
done I heard it got a nice round of
applause and the Netflix people
everybody was excited that uh that had
done well I hope I'm not boring you guys
with this [__] I feel like I'm babbling
here um and then it was the moment of
truth going on stage to do standup
comedy at Madison Square Garden sold
that [__]
show
and uh verie inted
me and I don't know I just walked out
there and I forget what I said but it
just was one of those things it's like
you hit your first shot and you're like
all right it's going to be a good game
and
um for the next 90 minutes I don't think
I've ever more more present I just
totally [__] enjoyed every last
second of it I did every joke that I
wanted to do I was improvising I was
[__] around I think I trashed Babe
Ruth at one point cuz me and jannis
Papas had this big about
it
[Music]
um and I ended up telling this story
about me and verie smoking a cigar in
his garage that's how I ended and
uh and it was over and I and I outro uh
the outro music oh I went on stage to
The Song Remains the Same cuz the name
of the show was does anybody remember
laughter it was just like a [__] per
it was a perfect night and then the
outro music was Frank Sinatra singing
New York New York which I thought was
perfect it was a nod to you know they
played at Yankee Stadium and everything
and Madison Square Gardens is such a
legendary venue and
uh and I got off dude and it was just it
was it was unbin everybody that I I care
about was backstage was flipping out
saying what a great show it was and
um yeah and I was worried I was worried
the only thing I was worried about was
that the next day I was going to have a
let down like I was going to have that
whole now what and you know the big you
know it's like after you open all the
gifts on Christmas you know that feeling
of melancholy I thought I was going to
feel that I didn't the next day I woke
up I just felt great I felt satisfied I
felt at peace I was just like if I never
get to do that again I couldn't have
done it any better and I I enjoyed every
last [__] second of it it was the
night of my life and of course I
recorded it and I will be putting that
one out on vinyl my ACT is not ready to
be a special yet but uh that will
definitely be and I'm putting out every
[__] second of that so it might be a
double album um I'll put that out
hopefully after my next special um but
it was it was incredible the only part
of the night that wasn't fun was uh when
we went to the
Afterparty um one of the people that I
work with
um know uh goes actually dates uh I
don't want to say their business dates
this guy who's a big [__] fan of the
UFC so somehow he had the UFC feed on uh
on his
computer and Nia was screaming going
Bill get over here get over here ronda's
having a tough time blah blah and I was
just talking to some people I didn't
want to be
rude
um and then I just saw Nia go oh my God
oh my God put her hand over her
mouth and
uh I went over there and I saw the
replayer Ronda getting knocked out and I
got to I haven't had a feeling like that
since I watched Tyson get knocked out
it's just something like you know you I
don't know I love greatness and I didn't
I didn't want to see you know I didn't
want to see that congratulations to
Holly Holm I hope I'm saying her name
right so she doesn't kick me in the
[__] jaw and neck but that was
[__] brutal brutal to watch and um
it's one of the reasons why I have such
respect for Fighters they know that that
they keep fighting eventually you know
On Any Given night even if somebody's
not as good as you you can just get
caught and I hate when something like
that happens and then people say yeah
you know you know what's up now [__]
and blah blah blah like you ever had the
balls to [__] go in there um I
obviously think Ronda is going to be
back I mean she's only 28 years old you
know whatever she got caught I actually
think now she'll probably become a
better fighter because uh that whole
[__] pressure of of um being
undefeated is gone and she can just
focus on what she needs to do but uh
that was [__] brutal man that was
really brutal it actually reminded me I
had this
flashback aside from the fact when I
watched Tyson get knocked out by Buster
Douglas I watched that uh over my
buddy's house up in his bedroom right we
were like I think we were underage yeah
we were underage no we weren't no we
weren't where we I can't even remember
how long ago I just remember we were
drinking
beers in his bedroom right and he had
this [__] TV in his bedroom which was
[__] ridiculous back in the day if
you had a [__] TV in your bedroom was
insane most houses had one TV and maybe
a little kitchen TV and we were watching
it on this [__] thing and
um I I just I just remember I I just
remember sitting there and hand over my
mouth I couldn't [__] believe it you
just never thought Tyson was going to
lose and I felt the same way about Ronda
and um but that's happened two times on
big gigs for me that there's been a big
fight where something unbelievable
happened
sorry drinking the tea here um the first
one was
uh was the first time I ever did Comics
come home which I believe was the second
one afterwards the
Afterparty was in this bar and they had
the Tyson Holyfield fight the one where
Tyson was biting Holyfield's [__]
ears and uh you know the bar was loud so
you couldn't hear the announcers so he
had no idea what was going on and the
second time when like Holyfield was like
grabbing
you know put his like gloves up like
trying to grab his ear and he was did
that [__] temper tantrum almost like
a little kid jumping up and down like
what the [__] going on with him man
looks like he's like on fire or
something and then somebody finally just
goes dude did he like dude did he
[__] bite his ear right and then all
of a sudden it just became that and then
you know when he went to the it was kind
of cool to actually see with the sound
down and they focus it on his ear the
blood and the little bit taken out of
his ear and everybody in the crowd just
going like dude what the [__] um and
that was beyond a surreal night it was
the first like big gig first time I ever
met Dennis ly and there was all these
famous guys on the show and liry knew
all these hockey guys Camy was there
[__] uh um Chris Nyon was there Rick
Middleton I couldn't [__] believe it
and then I'm watching this sick fight
and I'm watching them reacting like
regular fight
fans like going dude did he [__] bite
him in the air like well you know just
acting regular so
um I got to admit that was really
[__] tough to
see that was tough to see oh that
[__] picture of just taking that shot
man I I hate seeing that happens to just
about every other than Rocky Marciano
that happens to every great
Fighter um so anyway so that was that
night all right so here we go my Friday
Saturday Sunday so Friday I get to
[__] do the goddamn Comedy Jam in
front of 600 standing room only people
at the gramar seat
theater Saturday I Jam during the day in
an empty Madison Square Garden and I
have the set of my [__]
life at at this most famous arena and
all that [__] the Mecca and all that
crap that I always hate that they say it
you know as a Celtic fan but Boston
Garden doesn't exist anymore
um and then Sunday how do you top it how
do you top it where do you go I went to
the Giants Patriots game it's hilarious
me and a buddy of my we ubered over
there right and uh and we knew like
another like two or three other groups
of two that were going there we were all
looking for a tailgate we were trying to
meet up with each other we just showed
up like the guy just pulls up to like
the exit off of the highway and we just
get out there you know stumbling up the
[__] hill with a 12pack in our hand
and they led us into this this uh gated
area where they had tailgates I felt
like I was in like a tense City and we
were just wandering around like uh two
men without a country and and we finally
just ended up sitting on like this
jersey barrier oh I remember what
happened um couple more of my friends
showed up and they they were like did
you find a tailgate I was like N I
tweeted it out but nobody got back to me
about uh letting us crash that tailgate
and my buddy was like well when we
walked in these people asked us if we
had any
beers so we walked back over and we
literally traded beers for food and
joined their tailgate it was like uh we
were like fur Trappers instead of having
we had like [__] bud light and [__]
and um cooked us up some burgers they
were all giant fans and uh you know
breaking our balls about losing the
Super Bowl but you know we were cool
like yeah dude you guys [__] own us
we haven't beat you since the end of
2007 there's nothing we can
say I [__] love Eli you know he's a
big he's a [__] gamer but I hate him
because he always breaks our heart so we
[__] go in we watch the game I can't
even intelligently talk what was going
on I was still flying Ling so [__]
high from MSG and I was drinking of
course and um there was this little girl
kept giving her [__] tearing up stuff
and throwing it at us and we weren't
being [__] we laughed at it at first
and she just kept giving a [__] she was
like
seven you know at some point you're
looking at the parents like can can you
can you not have
uh her at behaving this way what are you
trying to do she's like going to be one
of the worst sports fans ever she's
going to get one of her boyfriends
knocked the [__] out when she gets older
cuz she's going to behave this way but
the person did nothing so
um we watched the game and I thought
once again you know once when we scored
that touchdown they called that [__]
holding call I was like ah here we go
here we go what's going to happen but
finally Tom Brady had some Eli football
God luck he threw a [__] pick to end
the game and they dropped it um so there
you go I said Eli was due I said the man
was [__] due to have a game where the
football doesn't bounce his way or
whatever but
uh it's not like he's screwed up or
anything he didn't throw a [__] pick
he actually threw a touchdown great play
by Malcolm
Butler um I didn't get to really see the
replay I saw in the Jumbo Tron but I'm
sure if I was watching it home I'd
probably say you know back in the day
that would have been considered a
touchdown um but who knows with these
whole new [__] football move rules or
whatever but um it was great dude it was
great to see them [__] win the game
and it was great to see you know to be
able to say that I saw Brady and Eli
play against each other live I saw Brady
and pton Manning play each other live
way back in ' 04 when Manning was still
on the Colts and hadn't won a Super Bowl
yet um so that was a great one to see
but it all paled in comparison to uh
doing Madison Square Garden so there you
go there's a 24 minute story of my
[__] last 3 days um I got to read
some advertising here but once again to
I I can't thank the people that showed
up
enough
[Music]
um that that that was it was unfuckin
believable you know what's funny when I
left too verie was was you know all
amped up and [__] and now you know I was
flying high it was just sick we walked
over to the
Afterparty right down like the streets
in New York and ver he was flipping out
going dude you realize what you just did
in there do you realize how hard you
realize and I was just like yeah yeah I
do it's the best I can [__] do and
then we went in I the after party drank
we smoked cigars it was [__] sick and
then ended the night with the bacon egg
and cheese as [__] it was the [__] it's
the [__] and now I'm on vacation um I
remember somebody said to me oh now what
now I'm trying to put that in my head
now what it's like what do you mean now
what now what now I enjoy my evening no
no what's next I don't give a [__]
like you're not supposed to be able to
top something like that what you're
supposed to go in there is enjoy every
[__] second of it and do the best you
can possibly do which is what I did so I
am to there there is no what's
next I don't I you know I I could
believe when the person asked me that
it's just like do you understand how
much I love doing standup I do it right
now in front of six people and if I got
a new bit out of it I'd still be
excited it's always got to be some kind
[__] ruining uhoh is my dog back hey
buddy look who's Home Cle get down Jesus
Christ hey what's going on all right all
right all right get down get down oh
Cleo hang on a second I haven't seen her
in two weeks I got to give her a proper
hello what do you say there buddy come
here what up buddy watch up buddy watch
up you got a bath look at you yeah okay
all right I'm doing the podcast I'm
doing the
podcast all right sorry sorry I'm back
I'm
back look at you huh the old blue
bear the old blue Bear's back in the
building I haven't seen my dog in two
weeks You and I Lady Cleo you and I are
going to go on some [__] hikes my
friend I'm in town for the rest of the
year what do you think about that you
know I put on some pounds and I'm going
to get back in Pitbull shape and I'm not
talking about the
rapper um all right buddy can you get
over there and lay down Cleo can you go
lay down please go on go lay down go lay
down no I'll play with you in a
minute hey get your nose out of there go
lay down down sorry is this even a
podcast anymore Cleo get the get over
there go on go on get over there lay
down you can't keep jumping up
here um all right let's do some reads
for this week you know what Cleo you're
too goddamn cute why don't you come up
here for the rest of the podcast all
right lay down lay down lay down lay
down thank you oh you smell so so good
yes you do okay
okay all right I
know I missed you too okay are you
done all right let's read some questions
for this
week um she'll calm down in a
minute uh military
response uh Bill I'm not affiliated with
any political
party um readed
extremist
whenever anybody says I'm not a democrat
or a
republican
um hold on you're just going to make all
kinds of [__] noise up here aren't
you all right I hate
groups just as much as you do I'm not
looking forward to hearing people argue
about proper responses to recent attacks
in Paris because everyone talks like
they have military background that being
said what is the solution it seems like
it's always a damned if you do and
damned if you don't situation with
military action in one sense I find that
comforting knowing that it's [__] up
either way it means we're just human
beings getting by
thoughts
um all right what do I think well
obviously you know what happened in
Paris is [__]
brutal and I don't see how that you know
even if I agreed with the political
agenda of whoever the hell did it like
that's not the way to get people to uh
pay attention to your plight to do stuff
like that
now having said that I live in a
superpower and I know that our bombs
don't always land on the right people so
I understand why countries don't get
along with each other
um and I've been to Paris twice and it's
my favorite city in the world and I
think the people are great and it's it's
just Brut Eagles of Death Metal were on
stage thank God they were all right but
just I can't imagine
what I
mean nobody was in that building is
going to be the same I mean it's just
like I I can't even imagine it's just I
actually I didn't even want to talk
about this stuff it's so [__] brutal
but um unfortunately I think that human
beings are uh hairless
Apes that can speak and
um and we're doomed to uh destroy one
another so try to enjoy every [__]
day before uh we do I mean that's the
only thing I mean there's no there's no
stopping um all the [__] that's going on
in the [__] world we're never going
to get along we're just not going to you
know there's no solution in the Middle
East whatever side you're on those
people hate each other for [__]
ever um the only way you know the only
way you could [__] do it is you'd
have to eliminate everybody but like
babies and you'd have to start over
again so all nobody told them the
[__] stories about why you should
hate these people right but even if you
left the [__] babies alone cuz there
this big [__] thing where they go you
know a baby comes into the world and a
baby isn't racist and a baby isn't this
and a baby isn't that um but you know
what a baby is it's a [__] human
being all right and so one of those
babies eventually is going to be a
sociopath one of them's going to be uh
an egomaniac is going to give into
jealousy and envy and it would just
start all over again in different parts
of the world for different [__]
reasons and uh people would not like
people because of how they looked and
it's just how we're wired I think
everything has a beginning a middle in
the end we're closer to the [__] end
unfortunately and
um you know that's why I don't watch the
[__] news anymore that's why I
I I I don't I don't understand why it is
the way it it is and there is no [__]
solution I know that's depressing and uh
enjoy your holidays
everybody I just what are you going to
do what are you going to do to stop
these people dude my dog just keeps
wagging her tail it's right here sitting
on a couch with your [__] dog man
right that's it playing music with some
friends of yours doing a comedy show
going after a dream just going after
what the [__] you want in life that's
all you can do you can do that and you
can recycle can try to use less
materials but other than that what do
you what do do you really think and all
the years of watching the [__] the
debates between Democrats and
Republicans do you Republicans do you
think they're ever going to [__]
agree you think they're ever going to be
like no I see your point you know if you
give the people a top more money they're
going to create jobs oh I get what
you're doing or the people on
Republicans are going to be like oh you
know what maybe we are taking too much
maybe we should [__] do this or do
that there there's no there's no [__]
solution it's just like when I was in
New York York you know they were talking
about you know all the homeless people
you know and people mental problems and
[__] that they just on the
street the the police chief goes the
solution was stop giving them money it's
just like all right and then what they
just go okay well I guess the city isn't
giving money and they're going to do
like what walk to Philadelphia with no
money and no food they're going to get
desperate
um you know and then if you give them
food and money then what does that mean
then they get their life back together I
have no [__] idea I
just I don't know I don't think there's
any
solution um and that's depressing and
it's not even funny that's why I don't
talk about that type of [__] so moving
along to the next happy [__] topic
all right boyfriend won't shut up and
let me listen to the game all right Bill
I've been in a relationship what you
[__] did you marry a hipster what you
want to put on the Sci-Fi my channel uh
Bill I've been in a relationship with my
wonderful boyfriend for a year I'm 29
and he is 33 that's a good age split
right there uh he's a wonderful man
treats me very well and we are very in
love but he has no respect when I try to
listen to the game I'm a diard Denver
Bronco fan and we live in Chicago it is
Sunday and the game is not being aired
locally because they're showing your
lamel Patriots instead lame ass
Patriots um yeah I get it we're
undefeated and you're not so it annoys
you I get it so you attack my team my
team of Patriots how can you not like
the Patriots that means you don't
support the troops uh so my only option
is to listen to the game on Denver
Broncos radio network you go you could
also get the NFL package you can not go
out drinking one weekend you could use
that money you could watch him every
week anyway she goes but my boyfriend
makes it impossible for me to listen to
it he keeps playing his stupid videos
during the game talks uh talks a lot
like the game isn't even on and he even
broke out into a song and started
vacuuming this is not a onetime
occurrence last week it was on and he
kept switching over to other games his
sports are hockey and baseball and I
never once interfered with his ability
to watch the Blackhawks and the Cubs yet
he makes it impossible for me to listen
to the Broncos the only sports team I
really care about Jesus Christ This
Guy's an [__] he doesn't seem to have
any respect for my team in sports fandom
it's surprising because he's so
respectful otherwise how do I handle
this going forward should I just always
leave and go to the bar because I know
he makes it impossible for me to watch
the game or listen and listen or watch
the game that's one of them that's one
solution why don't you just write down
on a piece of paper if you don't shut
the [__] up I will never blow you
again and then flip it over and say I'm
serious after he goes are you serious
right now I am
serious um
I don't know if you sat
down and uh talk to him about
it you know I don't know see then listen
see look at this right here this is a
little tension here half fields and
McCoy what do you do and if he doesn't
listen to you then you're going to get
resentful listen I would just politely
ask him not to do it if he does it again
the next time one of his games are on I
would
vacuum I just keep turning the vacuum on
on and off on and off and if you do that
to him for like 5 minutes he's going to
get it I think you got to go childish
here if you haven't talked to him yet I
think you got to go childish you know
there's always room to act like an
absolute [__] baby don't ever forget
that and it's
fun um all right Thanksgiving
dilemma uh hey Billy so I will get I
will get right to the details my family
is hosting Thanksgiving this year oh
Jesus we have five people in our family
mom dad and three brothers I am the
middle child we have grand grandparents
for both my mom and dad's side coming
along with my grandparents we have
cousins coming all right now here is my
dilemma here's my dilemma comes into
play my cousin got married a while back
and his wife has asked if her mom could
come to our Thanksgiving dinner oh Jesus
Christ oh Jesus Christ you know there's
there's something to be said when you've
lived that long and you don't have a
Thanksgiving party to go to that
probably means you're a [__] [__]
uh my mom had to go my mom had got into
a little dispute with her like a few
months ago and my mom [__] hates her
ah Jesus Christ you can't do that people
you can't get into a fight with your
[__] in-laws you can't do it you
can't get in a fight with your uh I
don't even know what you call them if
your brother or sister gets married you
can't get into it with their [__]
in-laws you just can't do it you got to
bite your tongue and just be like I'm
going to sit here in my sweater I'm
going to smile and wave and this is
going to be over and then I'm going to
go back to the life that I'm that I'm
leading that I built and I'll deal with
this person once a [__] year
right why is there always a [__] male or
female there's always that one [__]
person just doesn't know how to hang
doesn't know how to be a good person you
know what I mean like like if you're
annoying people on Thanksgiving which is
is who's kiding who that's just the
greatest day you're hanging with the
people you love you're eating way too
much food it's all Del ious everybody
from all different families and [__] is
breaking out their secret recipes
there's football on there's video games
you got the fire going there is no
[__]
reason to even remotely be a [__] on
that day or for the whole weekend it's
just a it's just a it's the greatest
[__] weekend college kids come back
Wednesday night everybody [__] hangs
out you get to try to [__] hook up
with people that that you liked back in
the day when you were in high school
right by the way you got to do that
Wednesday night hookup man you got to do
that until you're like [__] 30 and
everybody starts disappear and then you
got to realize you're too [__] old
and then maybe I should go out and
[__] uh you know maybe I should go
out and uh get married myself or
whatever but uh right through your 20s
you got to hit that every [__] time
in fact you know we did a great rant
about that The oneman Thrill Ride The
One Man Thrill ride's got a great one
I'll try to find that video
um he's got a great video about that but
anyways yeah there's no reason to be a
[__] I just don't [__] get it and
there's another thing too
like your mom needs to set aside her
[__] he had one [__]
argument all right let me go back and
read I already forget now this is
this your your mom's son's mother-in-law
you have to get along with
her my cousin got oh your cousin ah it's
a little distant just just be [__]
civil you know what's funny is when men
don't like each other it's way more
civil it's a family event like that
because we solve [__] with VI violence
you know what I mean no one wants to get
involved in that but women you know are
more mature I guess so they don't solve
[__] with violence so all it is is dirty
looks and
[__] you know sashy or sides or
whatever the [__] you call them side
glances and [__] they just all day long
they don't give a [__] they're just
being just openly being rude to one
another oh my God you know what you
should do you should you should have
like a
[__] I should just have an area to
put people like that all right you two
douchebags don't get along so you can
you guys can both eat you can eat
Thanksgiving dinner standing up outside
in the backyard that's where you should
stick them right the [__] out of here
all right my mom had got into a little
dispute with her a few months ago and my
mom [__] hates her she's the type of
lady that just sits on her ass and
doesn't help making food doing the
dishes cleaning up or anything yeah yeah
exactly there's always one of those we
know that yeah and and then [__] goes
to the your bar and and takes out the
most expensive [__] doesn't finish it
you know what I mean dumps it down the
[__] sink uh we know this from the
few times we hung out with her at family
gatherings my cousin's wife's mom has no
other place to go for Thanksgiving yeah
g why do you think that is
cuz she doesn't help making the food she
doesn't do the dishes she doesn't clean
up or anything she's a douche oh my God
I [__] hate this
person um but honestly none of us really
know her or nor do we want her to come
and make our day awkward I guess I just
need to ask advice on how we respond to
my cousin and tell him that that [__]
isn't invited we don't know how to do it
without hurting feelings or making it
weird the next time we see them um you
can bring Nia in on this one if she
knows
how to set this [__] down easy you know
what I'm going to go get her hang on one
second hang on one second hey Nia I need
your help on this
one all right even though you're still
mad at me for my my rude comment
earlier can you can you come over this
is this is this is recording live can
you Cleo get down get down buddy I'm
sorry get over there lay down go on Nia
I hear you what is it all right come
over here so long story short this guy's
got a dilemma he's having he's having
Thanksgiving at his
house okay so here's his dilemma his
cousin got married a while
back and his cousin's wife asked if her
mom can come along okay all right and
evidently she's a douche she doesn't
help with the cooking she doesn't help
with the cleaning she just sits around
she's a jerk okay and guess what she has
no place to go for Thanksgiving can you
believe it can you believe this jerk
come over here and near the microphone I
know I know just really quickly oh my
God you're so mad at me right now so
what's the question so how can he how
can he just in a nice way let this woman
Down Easy like how can he just say
listen we'd love to have your mother
over here if she wasn't such a jerk and
she wasn't going to ruin Thanksgiving so
wait so the cousin is coming the cousin
was invited yeah and he's bringing his
wife they're both invited they just
don't want them to bring
um his cousin's wife's
mom yeah that's an impossible situation
I feel you though because you want to be
like well it's my house I can have out
whoever I want over and if I don't want
this person over I shouldn't but the
thing is with the holidays and family
and this is the cousin's wife's mom
that's when you're not going to be able
to win so I feel like you can't turn
them down and say no they can't come
because that will create a bigger
problem than it's worth and so what what
does she do she just doesn't like my mom
got into a little dispute with her a few
months ago and my mom [__] hates her
oh it's
brutal okay well you know I love that
you have to be like the bigger person
and just allow this [__] stick in the
mud to come over and ruin this person's
Thanksgiving I really feel for this
person right this [__] blows I think
I think what you can do is oh especially
since the mom doesn't get along with her
I think it may be one of the those
things like you know what we're really
only prepared for like this many people
and but they had the fight and the
falling out they're going to know what's
up they're going to know why she's not
somebody says can can you can I bring my
mom you have to say yes you know your
mom could stay at home that's the thing
about it and the thing is I would I
think maybe this is more advice for the
next time next time you can't invite
your cousin over that's there it is
that's what it is this year's
Thanksgiving is going to stink but then
the rest of them won't because your
cousin can't come the next time yeah
just I mean just ignore that woman for
now if she doesn't help or whatever it's
you know whatever you got to have fun
with it yeah and you can also say oh hey
um you know whatever her name is Susan
do you mind you know Gathering a couple
of those plates for us and you know just
kind of like just throw that in there
but if she's continuing to be that way
I'm sorry but your cousins can't come to
your Thanksgiving anymore because she's
going to be a part of the package and if
they bring it up just say you know what
to be honest our mom doesn't really get
along with her and we feel like it gets
uncomfortable and you know maybe they
can come by for pie at the end of the
night or something and they can just
maybe we can bring it out to the car and
just hand it to you right as as they're
as they're driving by as they're driving
by just just stick your hand out the
window and I'll just have it on a I'll
have it on a plate you know we used to
do when there was somebody like that
around we would there would be some sort
of inside joke that whenever the person
was behaving the way that we hated it
was the inside joke with the other
people where you would just like sing a
song you hey can you clean up the dishes
and she doesn't do it and then you just
walk away and you just sing like just
what can we try and it just becomes and
it actually makes it fun but I really
think you should just do the thing where
you ask her to help out hey do you mind
grabbing the plates and setting them out
you're so good at that too I do do that
really well I'm really good at like oh
do you mind just grabbing this for me
really quickly it's all laced with with
hey do you mind not being such a selfish
douche yeah exactly like it's you know
it's it's customary when you're invited
to somebody's
place over to dinner or anything can I
help you with the dishes do you need
anything like that's a custom even if
the person's like no no no no no I got
it I got it I got it it's it's customary
it's an etiquette thing to at least ask
if you can help out or bring wine or
something like that yeah and here's
here's a major red flag if you're that
[__] old and you have nowhere to go
for Thanksgiving and there wasn't some
boating accident that all your family
was on like how do you not have anywhere
to go nobody wants to spend Thanksgiving
with you pick up a dirty plate you
selfish [__] well the thing is like the
cousin and the wife and the cousin's
mother-in-law they they can't do their
own thing separately I mean Maybe not
maybe it's well it's all about the big
family gathering but I think that's I
think you just got to grin and bear it I
think you should definitely gently
suggest to her hey do you mind grabbing
this just little stuff not crazy cuz
then she'll be on to you and it'll be
like a real big blowout and you don't
want that but just subtly hey uh hey
turkey douche you might uh you might
exactly but next year yeah just can't
invite you know what we're actually
going to do a really small Thanksgiving
this year just going to be me and the
wife and my mom like no [__] we're
just doing a small this year you have to
be very gentle about it but that's how
you get around it is that you just don't
invite the people that are attached to
the people that that you don't like
which sucks but that's how it goes
here's the other thing watch watch watch
watch your alcohol intake because your
the truth might be coming out later on
you might say something and the alcohol
will start going like no say it say [__]
it's your hey it's your Thanksgiving too
I need you sign this I will do that okay
who do I make this out to can I give a
shout out to uh can we shout out
Justin absolutely shout out to Justin
Long and his brother Christian long um
they listen to podcast and they're
awesome Justin you know what I found out
the next day after we met each other you
and I have the exact same birthday the
exact same birthday month day year how
crazy is that and why was Justin there
he was there because he does a voice on
FIS for family coming to Netflix on
December 18th yeah there you go and he's
been so great man he tweeted out uh you
you know he was tweeting the hell out of
the uh the teaser and all that and uh he
he does the voice of Kevin and he is
[__] hilarious and it's one of my
favorite characters to write for once I
saw what Justin was going to do with it
so uh um we had a lot of fun hanging
with them well Nia thank you so much the
lovely Nia everybody thank you so much
yeah coming on the podcast to support to
support you at the Maden Square Garden
you were incredible you were amazing you
were in the zone I was very proud of you
thank you thank you and now I'm telling
you I'm NE I'm uploading this and I'm
taking a shower and then I'm put on my
pajamas and that's it oh that's it
that's it it's over all right one more
question here one more question I got to
get through here oh I got to feed you oh
yeah get CLE some food all right gay
rumors dear Billy
Twinkletoes uh my friends and I are
freshmen in college at different schools
recently he hooked up with this girl
with this
lady it was after the party had died and
everyone uh was cleared out she crawled
into his
bed Jesus Christ I started jacking him
off and that's how it
happened that's how what
happened he had a hand
baby it's kind of open-ended there I was
visiting that weekend and I watched her
walk into his
room the rest I heard second hand from
him no pun intended the next day she
started talking like they were in a
relationship um he explained that he
wasn't into being in a relationship
aside from the fact that she's a slob he
wasn't into the idea anyways with any
girl um she responded by telling a group
of people that he asked her to be his
girlfriend to covered that he was gay
and that he needed to meet needed her to
meet his parents can you oh she just
made that up can you believe this chick
that's sociopathic Behavior yeah it's
slander my question obviously is what
should he do he's not a feeble Soul he's
actually really quick witted and if he
really wanted to he could air he could
clear the air publicly it's one of those
situations where if he lets it all fade
away it could it could end clean on the
other hand [__] that she shouldn't get
off that easily uh she could do it again
and the next guy could respond with
violence or suicide or some [__] what's
the move here you know what the move
here is to [__] watch that crazy
train just go down the street and
disappear over the hill [__] her that's
[__] hilarious it's hilarious that
she said that that she's you know she's
a maniac why would you do that you know
what I
mean gives a [__] he how easy it to play
are you you gay well I mean I am a sharp
dresser you you got to give me that who
knows maybe I am maybe I'm not I don't
know hey ladies you want to see if you
can UNG me like they do with the [__]
those weird churches where they try to
cure you being gay I would just have fun
with it who gives a
[__] honestly who gives a [__] some slob
says that you're gay all
right well I'm not and I can prove it
show me your tits ladies oh look at Old
Frederick standing up at attention
[Laughter]
yeah this is this is like childish who
gives a [__] who gives a [__] what
people
think
um yeah I mean that's that's it's a joke
she's going to do it to somebody else
yeah okay and then what she keeps going
around oh that guy doesn't like me he
doesn't like me cuz he's gay
um I don't know maybe she's uh maybe
she's that much of an eag Maniac that
she thinks the only way that you could
not 100% be into her is because that you
you liked men because evidently she's
just the most amazing [__] woman of
all time uh yeah when people walk around
they say [__] like that to you I mean if
you have like a business and somebody's
trying to say like yeah hey I got food
poisoning there I mean you got to put a
stop to that but you
know Hell hath no fury like a woman
scorn like you you haven't hooked up
with a woman dated a woman you know
unless you've had a woman go around and
just make up [__] about you and say a
bunch of
[__] stuff to try and hurt you that's
what they do she wants to beat the [__]
out of them but she can't so she's doing
what women do is they you know they just
go around saying [__] about each other
that's what they do you know this woman
is acting completely normally this is
what completely normally completely
normal this is normal chick psycho
[__]
behavior um I think it's [__]
hilarious and uh I yeah I would just let
it go yeah don't don't we can't let her
get away with this you can't go
Vengeance Vengeance never that never
ends well it never ends well because
they're then they're going to come back
and get their Vengeance on your
Vengeance and then eventually the only
way to end it is somebody's got to kill
somebody right that's basically what
happens is it I don't know if it is all
I know is it's the end of the podcast
and I am on [__] vacation and um I
want to thank everybody over all the
years of coming out to my standup shows
anybody ever heckled me anybody ever
laughed anybody who just [__] showed
up got a free [__]
ticket um because all of those shows led
to the one that I had Saturday night
what a [__] way to end I got one more
gig that I am I am doing New Year's Eve
out here in um in uh in LA but it's not
a road gig it's going to be great it's
going to be the night before the Rose
Bowl it's going to be the four horsemen
coming together
again um it's going to be [__]
awesome but
um I don't know I hope I was able to
convey it I can't even tell you what a
how just [__] thrilled I was I still
can't believe that it happened but I
know it happened cuz I was totally
present and I enjoyed the whole thing
and you know what's great the light was
so in my eyes I couldn't see
how big it was I couldn't see everybody
but I I could look up and see the lights
up at the top and
uh one of the coolest things ever my
comedy career at one point I was doing
this Illuminati act out like they were
all sitting at a table talking about the
population problem and I actually sat
down on the
stool and I was doing this creepy
[__] thing about them thinking about
how they could get rid of people and I
was able to bring the whole [__] room
down like like I was in a [__] comedy
club and as I was doing it I was
actually thinking like how [__] sick
is this right now it's like 12,000
people listening to me I'm sitting down
on a stool imitating some lunatic in the
Illuminati how [__] fun is that it
was it's was
Indescribable and anyways please tell
everybody you know about FIS for family
um I would really appreciate it um
although after Saturday night nobody
owes me anything but if you'd like to I
would appreciate it because uh I think
it's going to be a great
show um a great TV series for many years
to come with any luck all right that's
it so I'm thankful early this year man
I'm thankful for all you guys listening
to this podcast and all that stuff um
that's it so go [__] yourselves as
always I'll check in on you on Thursday
check in on you I'm going to go take a
shower and put on my PJs and play with
my [__] dog all right that's it I'll
see
you
[Music]
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast show NFL
Edition preview for week number 11 oh my
birthday 1111 baby um we are coming in
hot this week okay we are coming in hot
this week we uh we hit the special we'll
talk about that we uh have a winning
record we'll talk about that and uh oh
and there's some injuries some big
injuries that the NFL's trying to hide
they tried to Bamboo they tried to slip
one out from under us we weren't gonna
let that happen but before we get into
this week let's talk about our sponsor
it is BET MGM everybody the best app the
best lines the best way to bet all you
got to do for our show if you're a
listener to our show you just if you
listen to our show you just go to bmgm
app you download the app and you put in
as little as $10 okay and you'll get
$200 in bonus bets regardless of the
outcome of your bet all you have to do
is use our code our bonus code Burr TW
uh bur2 200 buur r200 $10 as little as
$10 and they will give you $200 in bets
regardless of the outcome of your bet
bet responsibly have a good time and uh
here we are over three quarters of the
way done the NFL season bill it's like
your kids growing up it happen so
fast yeah I baseball for some reason
they're regular season is six months and
the NFL is essentially four months
that's why in the NFL if a team goes 0
and three you're like ah should they
tank yeah it's it's freaking over um
Paul the big thing is we finally hit a
Monday night special and now and you
know finally hit a Monday night every
every [__] time there was some little
damn thing finally made some people some
money paulist which means I get to sing
again and and I gotta be honest with you
dude I got to give you credit where
credits do we hit the Monday night
special because of you my friend because
I wanted no part of Denver and when you
saw the seven and a half you were like
take Denver and I was like all right you
know what it doesn't make sense to me so
it's gonna work and well that's the
Buffalo Bill season oh I found the
Buffalo Bill season doesn't even make
sense to the Buffalo Bills and I still
am am believe Stefon Diggs was talking
about it he goes you know we got all the
pieces we're going to I just don't see
these guys there's no [__] way
they're going to go 9 and8 or eight and
nine they just they're just not I feel
like they're going to do what I think
the Chiefs are going to do what the
Chiefs always do this time of year
because everybody's oh the [__]
Chiefs are done bah blah ba they always
say that [__] and then they [__] turn
it on they they just they just you know
what it's a bike race Paul they just
[__] laying back they're not burning
out their legs and then they're gonna
come on I think the bills are going to
do something like that I feel like the
Dolphins are fading you know I feel like
I'm directionless right now in this
football season you know I'm just out
there with my sales down and I'm just
[__] letting the tide take me where
it's going Paul it's about me it's not
really about the bills is it ever not
listen here's the
thing I have a theory on why the bills
are bad and I talked to somebody and I
think it was uh I think it was kind of
confirmed let's just say oh Paulie
scuttlebutt here we go Paulie
[Laughter]
shefer a source that I have within the
locker room um wait so this is week 11
so I think this is
your this is your you go yeah because
you were Paul you're not just going to
tell the people that you got something
going on with the bills and not tell
them what you got going on I'm hang I
will talk I will talk about it because
Hey listen hey it's a football show
here's the deal it's a football season
show here's the deal I I jokingly texted
with some friends and I said something's
going on with Josh Allen and I think it
might be uh I I and it was not to be
just respectful to women but I think he
might be going through something you
know you go through a breakup oh you
don't have to be respectful to women on
this thing don't [__] do that no I'm
saying listen your Chain's outside your
shirt people know where you stand on
feminism all right don't buyback what
the [__] you're doing here just tell me
what's up he's got some broad in his
life and it's [__] his head up is
that what you're saying I thought that
that's what it was and then all of a
sudden yesterday something comes out
going hey the break up with this one and
now he was spotted with this one and I'm
going oh that's why he overthrew that
ball by five yards oh that's what it is
he's he's a Serial mon U monogamist is
that what it is no whatever the [__] it
is the guy the guy who breaks up with a
chick and then immediately gets into
another relationship Bill let's say
you're about to go out there modern day
Gladiator you're about to go play an NFL
team you got these 350 PB guys running
after you wanting to hurt you and right
before you get out there you get on your
cell phone and some girls like how the
[__] are you doing this to me
Josh it's like all right dude let me
just I got a g got another
girlfriend so like what over the house
she was over my house he's like look
dude I got a game just give me 10
minutes I'll call you lat I'm just a
simple kid from Wyoming wherever the
[__] he played um yeah so this is a this
[__] that dude they can turn that [__]
off you can turn that off you they go
into a hostile environment every other
weekend if you can go into [__]
Philly or go into like the Raiders they
got these loud [__] uh Hot Dog Eating
jerk off screaming at you saying stuff
about your mother if you can block that
out you can't well a woman you have
feelings for she knows where all the
pressure points are does doesn't she I
mean dude if I'm about to go on stage
and Stacy's like your clothes are on the
front lawn you piece of [__] it might be
a tough set that does affect the first
couple of
jokes
uh uh your daughter's mad at you I told
her be like oh god dude anyway listen
it's it's an odd week which means I
think you pick first oh God and I was
ready for that this is like when you go
to a restaurant you're not ready to
order yet somebody goes no you go you go
yeah um I hate when you know what I
[__] hate is when people [__] go
to order and they just start what do you
like here what do you like just just
make a [__]
decision I defer [__] do I like here you
know I like here when my shift is over
that's what the [__] I like here here's
another one Paul I'm in a mood if one a
[__] adult comes walking in and
pretends they don't know what a line
looks like and they oh is is this is
this the line it's like you mean the
line yeah you think that human beings
just every once in a while just
naturally [__] hang out face to back
in a [__] line yeah oh are you guys
in line the eight people in the line
that we're [__] standing in over here
you [__] yeah we are in line you know
what in line Looks like um all right
Paul I don't like any of these games
this week but is it am I really
commenting on myself is it that I don't
like myself
Paul am I nervous that like football's
going to leave me again in [__] 10
weeks then I'll have [__] sad dude
it's so [__] sad I mean the for
goddamn baseball they they play until
the first week of
November they did add a week though
didn't they they did add a week to the
season all right Paul oh you know
there's a lot of games here that are
very
interesting oh Jesus
um I don't know I keep riding that
Texans bandw and they're still being
good to me although uh what's his face
is
back um at quarterback
right the little water bug there Barry
Sanders playing quarterback why can't I
remember his name oh Kyler Murray Kyler
Murray look at Jake Jake's on it Kyler
Murray he's coming back Kyle or Murray
um no I hate every [__] game here
what is with these giant [__]
spreads uh what's going on with your boy
there
who uh Sal volcano [__] quarterback
for the
Giants I love a divisional rivalry with
a nine and a half point
spread he's Italian he's still living at
home she's washing his [__] socks
over there I like this guy is he walking
down the street holding a bucket of
paint is he going to be strutting this
week
Paul not because they won just because
they [__] covered I don't know man
that's a tough one
what's going on with the Buccaneers why
are they 11 and a half Point underdogs
is Baker Mayfield uh is he
hurt is he in a cast is he walking into
the stadium missing a limb what's going
on yeah that's a high line dude for that
game it is a high
line Jake do we have I'm gonna take that
I don't give a [__] I'm gonna take the
Buccaneers and the NFC South scares the
[__] out of me it's 11 and A2 points you
know like you know I like Paul I like a
nice comfortable first quarter
with a whole bunch of points sitting in
my lap and I'm sitting there with a big
dumb look on my face as the 49ers start
hacking away at it yeah I'm like all
right there's only 38 minutes left in
this game still up by four and a half
there he is Jake Rothstein what do we
got oh Jesus turn your mic on
everybody's healthy so everybody's
healthy yeah if you like Baker then
that's hey dude I like that I don't like
how you said if you like Baker I know if
you like Baker if that's kind of you
know I do like Baker Baker Mayfield's a
[__] winner I think that'll even give
him a garbage time touchdown even if
they are I think the Buccaneers I got
the Buccaneers 11 and a half oh God I am
such dude I such a [__] dad with two
kids under the age of seven and you're I
barely know who's even in the NFL right
now and you're right there your Billy
win some lose some hover Billy win some
lose some I've had one three in one week
two one and threes the rest have been
two and
two all right I like that I think that's
a back door cover late Baker gets a
garbage touchdown you get those points
all right guys here's my first pick my
first pick uh it has to happen it has to
happen so that's why I'm going to take
it and uh it's no uh I'm no stranger to
this team but I'm gonna take the uh
former San Diego Chargers now Los
Angeles Chargers uh minus three against
a bad Packers team a three and six
Packers team and um the Chargers need to
the Chargers lost a heartbreaker to the
Lions with a field goal last second and
I think Justin Herbert gets his team
back to uh 500 because they were playing
really good until they ran into the
lions so I think that this is a perfect
line and a perfect game for a team
that's better I got the Chargers minus
three all right I got the Vikings plus
two and a half oh in Denver just because
you know what is Denver goingon to win
like three out of four weeks I don't
think that that that that I don't know
it was just something about the watching
the way Russell Wilson was throwing like
I don't know what's going on with that
guy he was behind he was over the head
it just like that one throw to the back
of the end zone that's the guy I know
and I can't understand what the [__]
problem is out there I think they're
figuring it out which I'm really happy
for because I like Shawn pyton but
uh I don't know the Vikings just have
this [__] way about them even though
I know they're their quarterback what's
it Jake plumber he's not in this week uh
who is it is it uh Jeff George who who
do they birie they got what's his name
now this Josh dos kidw
H um you're thinking of Kirk Cousins
he's hurt Kirk Cousins Kirk Cousins
scores points he made me a lot of
[__] money last last year when he was
on the Colts is it last year all right
I'm gonna take
another oh this is this has got Paulie
this is this is old Paulie this is
Paulie favorites Paulie favorites yes
you know me I see a good team in
favorite I get a little
jittery I'm still going to rehab for
that
habit what do you got I'm
Tak I just picture me talking to a
doctor I don't know there's just
something when I when I see that little
minus sign um I'm a positive
guy I'm gonna take the Jacksonville
Jaguars minus 6 and a half against the
Titans um another three and six bad team
I think the Titans are phito and um I'm
gonna take the Jags having to win the
game by a touchdown at home all right
I'm going back to the AFC East
Paul the [__] division that that
birthed me here I'm gonna oh
man I like both of I like both of these
[__] games all of a sudden I didn't
like them a minute ago and I haven't
read one more shred of information all
of a sudden I feel like I'm seeing
things um
I'm just going to say [__] it and I'm
going to take the Dolphins laying 13 and
a half because the Raiders do not have a
[__] quarterback oh no I'm not doing
that I just know the Raiders are going
to show up [__] that I'm gonna take the
bills instead I'm G take the bills one
of them I like the bills I just didn't
the Jets beat him the first time Jets
beat him the first time bills are gonna
win the second time I think uh they're
gonna have like another team meeting
some else is going to call a team
meeting I think uh you know uh uh you
know that [__] big eyed dude they're
playing quarterback I don't know with
the Jets they just can't move the
[__] ball they do have a great
defense but they just can't move the
ball and what's going to happen is that
they're gonna keep three and out three
and out three and out and as great as
that Jets defense is Paul they're GNA
get tired they're gonna want to put
their [__] cleats up and sit down for
a [__] second and right as they get
their helmet off Paul they're going back
out there again so I think in the second
half the bills a pull away and they're
going to cover that seven points for me
Paul a I like it your description of the
your just by the way another great pick
you had last week was the Browns and
what you said about them happen imagine
the team meeting Paul every week I have
two good ones and two [__] ones you know
I mean oh Billy Bruce Springsteen write
a St song about that same old story
that's a fact two [__] winners two
step back isn't that how it goes oh I
don't know um okay I'm gonna take for my
third pick this is where it
gets all right
I it's a tough game but I'm gonna take
the Kansas City Chiefs at home on Monday
Night Football I love that minus two and
a half I love that yeah I think that uh
you know I think uh what's his name's
gonna play with a little more pep in his
step because his old country singer
girlfriend's gonna be in the box with
her parents I'm gonna take them to win
by a field goal uh on Monday Night
Football I love that you know who else
loves the Chiefs I feel like the
official love the Chiefs I got all
favorites though and that's not good
dude it's not good hey Paulie two and
two I'll Paulie win some lose
some um I think Sneaky Pete's coming
down to [__] the Rams you know they
know each other minus one oh they're
they're not favorite I don't like that
no they are sneaky PE mean they're not
getting points is what I meant to say I
don't like that God damn it yeah this
last one's
tough the commanders are [__] hapless
and the Giants literally have some guy
from a deli playing [__] quarterback
I mean I don't know what to do
here this [__]
guy
um why do I [__] believe in the
Seahawks all the time Paul why can't I
get off the Seahawk [__] they yeah
them the Titans they just [__] cover
the Texans minus 4 and a half am I going
going back to that game Kyler Murray I
love Kyler Murray dude the Texans are
good man I know they are good you know
what I'm going to go with them by the
way shout out to Mike burkwitz two weeks
ago he told me to [__] take the
Texans which I did and I got a victory
old Billy win some lose some all right
old Billy win some lose some's taking
the Texans minus 4 and a half Paul I'm
so all over the map this week I don't
even know who the [__] I have I don't
remember just so you
know five and a half the line's five and
a
half but I four and a half five and a
half you know this reminds me when I
[__] you be like doing dishes you
know and right as you're done somebody
comes in and puts another [__] plate
in that's what the [__] just you just
want to look at them and you know they
didn't do it on purpose but it's kind of
like you know if you brought that over
30 seconds earlier it would have been
nicer I don't think there's a difference
in four and a half five and a half
though really well Paul that's the
difference between you and me what's the
difference between you and me well you
can go in the sun and the sun likes you
the sun doesn't like me right you see no
difference between four and a half and
five and a half and I do you're better
with the sun I feel like I'm better with
numbers although you keep beating the
book and I don't
um are the Lions gonna really win why
does it have to be seven and a half you
Vegas
[__]
um [__] it sneaky pee minus one oh
sneaky PE minus one sneaky pee boom I'm
doing the Trump dance dude Sneaky Pete
and you are you're the Seahawks to you
are like the Chargers to me you just
can't sne P one of the best [__]
coaches that like just doesn't kind of
get his due
cuz he's not parcel's he's not [__]
uh bellich oh my last pick I'm not going
to lie this is throwing a dart at it
this this one is not the other ones I
looked at and I go yeah I could sleep
this you're trying to hit a piñata right
now you're blindfolding you just
swinging like a
maniac everybody standing around going
oh oh
hey that Cowboy's pant pan line is just
so [__] perfect 10 and a half if it
wasn't 10 and a half I would take that
but um my brother took the
Panthers and he's he's picking winners
dude he's he's in a pool he's just
picking winners dude he picked the
[__] Jets a few weeks ago he had the
Jets and somebody else two big upsets
did you take the Raiders bill or
no no I didn't I I the [__] Raiders
just disappoint me they have so much
goddamn Talent except that the quarter
back position so they can't get the
[__] thing moving got all those
receivers Paul they going no want to
throw it to them they got that killer
defense I'm gonna take oh Crosby's
questionable o Max Crosby oh oh Paul you
got I gotta tell you about Max Crosby
okay he's the straw that stirs the drink
here's the thing though that guy's an
animal he doesn't miss games that you're
gonna have to [__] they'll tape that guy
together he's gonna go out there listen
I have all favorites this week I'm gonna
take some points I'm gonna take the
Raiders getting a back door cover 133
and a half who knows let's see what
happens could be a loss I'm going take
it the
Rota coming in the back door those son
of a [__] um all right yeah I don't
know about this pick but 13 and a half
points to start the game is not bad so
there you go um Paul you're like [__]
George Brett we're just every season
he's flirting with 400 it's [__] you
know it's not August yet we're getting
into the dog days this summer and there
you you're right there Paul look you're
[__] hitting like
420 I'm nine games above the book right
now it's not good enough yet you're nine
games up um
yeah [__] Paulie ver I'm 23 I mean
you you're you like I I say by the end
of this season you get a book
deal people should read the [__] wait
or or maybe I'm eight and a half eight
and no nine nine with the two with the
two
pushes um I mean Paul that is a Gody
Gody record I'll tell you what dude if I
beat the book again I'm getting another
chain I'm getting another gold chain
that always goes on when I do picks I've
earned that if I I mean who's gonna
argue with you uh bill you know what
time is be three years but that would be
three years in a row beating the book
Paul I mean you should have three chains
please tell me you have one on order it
just hasn't come in yet well I'm GNA get
one with my record there will be 20
years into this show you look like
[__] Mr
T
uh bill you know what system they'll pay
for a hair system so you can grow the mo
Mohawk they'll just glue it on before
every
show each year it gets more of a
man but two years from now I look like
bartnik you know I was thinking like you
know you couldn't be like totally
[__] bald and then get a [__] hair
system people notice when you get a hair
system if you're starting to go bald but
if you're completely bald and all of a
sudden one day you you just show up hey
I said don't touch my hair and then you
hit it you can't
come with the with the [__] barbarina
right you can't do that well Dion
Sanders did it h yeah dude and so did
Jason uh what's his name Brian eracer
Brian eracer was bald his whole career
as a linebacker for the Bears now the
kids got a [__] full
head I know that's so weird it's like
the old you looks like the young driver
license you know when you pull it out
going oh look at you with hair they they
they live in
Reverse I said on stage the other night
I go I would definitely want hair than
being bald but I definitely would rather
be bald than have a man
bun that's [__] hilar oh dude those
are going to be when they make fun of
this era you know when they go back and
do like the anchor man that's going to
be like that's the haircut that they're
going to uh they're going to make fun of
oh man I saw somebody the other day who
the [__] was it for the hair Hall of
Fame and I was like write this down
you're going to forget it I saw somebody
too I saw somebody and I go dude that's
for the show the guy had oh dude guy was
probably in his late 50s 60s and he had
a [__] who was
it oh
man ah I forgot I'm trying to think I
was I watched a couple episodes of
Cojack last night my son loves Cojack
now I know three and a half years old
like he was like yelling when we was on
so I thought he he wanted me shut it off
but he just saw the remote in my hand he
thought I was going to turn it off and I
said oh do you like Cojack he goes yeah
Cojack
yeah that's amazing my brother's out
here and uh we just said we watched two
episodes of Cojack we barely heard any
of the dialogue all we were doing were
calling out cars that's go he's like
Bill look at that that's a [__] AMC
Pacer he picked out another one it was a
1977 Chevy chevet uh sunlike yellow I
mean it was just like that's like it was
like a substitute teacher car that those
are the cars that I love seeing you know
because the classic
ones you know people still have them you
see them in car shows but those ones
that you just never see before anymore
like I saw a guy had a Chevy Monza out
here you don't even remember that car
that car came and went that they made
that car it [__] flopped Paul like a
number one draft pick and they made it
for like three four years the shf when
last time you saw Chevy
citation like that's the type of [__]
yeah you gotta watch like
Vegas yeah Chevy citation I never even
heard the name citation dude when they
made the design first of all it like
they didn't know they made like a
four-door sedan and a hatchback and they
just slammed it together Oldsmobile made
a car like that too it was one of the
ugliest [__] things I've ever seen it
looked like in the front it looked like
a full-size car and in the back it
looked like a skateboard ramp it was the
ugliest [__] thing I I'd forgotten
about it right and uh
anyway the Chevy citation I've told this
I know I've told this a thousand [__]
times they when they made the design at
the last second they realized that they
had forgot to put the radio
in so they turned it sideways it was
straight up and down the volume knob was
up here turned the station here but
here's the thing but the the numbers
were they didn't change the numbers like
because it was straight up and down they
still had it like it was horizontal so
you had to go yeah that's ridiculous my
buddy had it was like a thermostat but
it was a
radio that's what see that's what kills
me when these [__] idiots first of
all the the the gas combustion people
they're how much they're in an uproar
about the Tesla like they're making fake
videos about how cheap the Tesla is and
they're pushing down on the dashboard
and they're adding all of these these
sound effects I literally had to go to
my wife's car like no doesn't make that
[__] sound like what are you talking
about they just they have to do
something because they're so [__]
fast and what's funny is they look at
them they look boring they don't look
fast and then no matter what they do to
their car this [__] dude you see the new
one that's coming out 0o to 150 miles an
hour in 10 seconds first of all why
would you give somebody that's going to
be texting while D they're driving a
missile the thing's a missile so now
everybody's like would you rather do
have pizza in the microwave or in a
brick oven like that somebody came up
with that analogy now everybody's saying
it's like buddy nobody's saying you
can't buy a gas combustion
car like what like they can't they can't
even you know what it is they can't
handle the fact that something that
makes no noise and doesn't look cool is
just blowing by
there driving down the [__] it's
hilarious dude I like the new three I
like the new three I'm glad they changed
the body of the of the they're changing
they're starting to change the body of
them I'll tell you what dude that cyber
truck everybody [__] on it dude that
is [__] badass man I know I like all
the old [__] I I like I like the sound
of an engine and all that and I know
those [__] batteries and all that
they're probably worse for the [__]
planet and everything but I'm not going
to sit there and get like all these
people get [__] crazy in these
comments going like you know you know
back in the day we used have
car you know
I love how people like oh like who have
like loud cars think they're more manly
it's like what about that makes you more
you know I [__] hate a I'll be honest
with you like I I'm not trying to [__]
on muscle cars that like Roar but I love
a you know me Bill I just I'm going to
Lexus today to go pick up my they just
[__] did my maintenance on mine Paul
you're refined you're a gentleman I like
turning that [__] on barely hearing it
stepping on the gas and [__] flying
dude put that [__] in sport [__] cozy
man yeah why why does it have to make
all that [__] I understand it with a
motorcycle because you want people to
they can't see you they can hear you you
don't die but I don't understand why
like like to a certain volume I get you
know although I'm not gonna lie to you
uh remember that kid Casey that painted
the cars on uh Fast and Loud he just
upgraded his Frankenstein truck he's got
this F100 lowered to the ground it's
green calls it Frankenstein he put a
th000 horsepower engine in it I watched
this video three times of him doing a
burnout in it was [__] it was amazing
he gave me a r his that truck one time
when he and I think it was only like 700
horsepower I had my feet up on the
dashboard going dude Slow Down slow down
yo I'm not gonna lie man I was not a
Tesla guy until I drove one home from
New York City to my house and I [__]
dreamed about it I actually was like I
need this in my life the speed like how
I would say the speed is is [__]
insane I will tell you this I [__]
hate that car it just thinks too much
you [__] walk I I know you can
somewhere in the setting shut this off
but it's just it keeps it tries to
anticipate it's like you're doing too
much so I'm walking up to the car and I
have the key in my pocket so the front
door pops open like that but the problem
was was my three-year-old was coming
around the other side so it [__] pops
open and hits somebody he falls into a
bush jeez was he he's okay I take it he
was all you know he had big puffy coat
on you know when they walk around they
already look like they're in a fat suit
you know but it was just like it just
does that or like when you open the
stupid Falcon doors if there's just one
little debris thing it thinks like it's
I don't know what the top of a parking
garage and then you gota like push it up
it's come down on my [__] head I'm
not uh you know it's got that giant
[__] tablet thing I'm not I'm not
into uh you have to use the tablet for
every move I think if it was voice
activated it would be better but the
fact that you got to hit that thing and
I don't like not seeing things in front
I like seeing the speedometer and I like
seeing that there for me but uh hey I'm
old school what do you I will tell you
the Ford Lightning truck looks cool and
then there's that other one that's not a
Ford I don't know what it is but the
couple of dads have one in my
neighborhood the just like a uh I don't
know what kind of it is it just looks
cool like I kind of like I like the
electric trucks that look like a [__]
truck but um
you know my F250 do with the [__]
turbo diesel I mean it sounds like a
[__] semi I love that thing if I get
a new house if we get a new house and I
don't know if we're gonna if we get a
new house or we extend this house and
get a bigger garage I'm getting that
[__] cyber truck dude I'm gonna get
it I don't I is that the one that looks
like a door
wedge it does I hated it and then
somebody gave a whole tour of it and I
was like dude dude you get one of those
your side piece is going to be some blue
chick from like
[Music]
Venus you're going to be tracting [__]
from another planet from yeah like
[__] Captain Kirk just gy of the
Galaxy g of the Galaxy um all right bill
you know what time it is dude by the way
oh you know what time it is before you
sing before you sing guys we told you we
were gonna get one we were one little
piece away for a while and we finally
hit the Monday night special and I gotta
I gotta give uh a lot of the credit to
my counterpart here the co-host because
you said Denver but Bill you know what
time it is it's the E you know another
thing too to tell the fans why I took
that sh take it personally like I feel
like I'm letting them down it's like we
got to win him some money here oh dude
we got a lot of we got a lot of messages
from people going I rode with you guys I
put 20 down and they're showing that
they hit and they're like we rode with
you we stuck with you you finally hit it
we got to hit another one Paul we got to
hit another one dude all right let's
sing the song here I could sing again oh
let the Monday night special win some
money for you let the Monday night
special and some [__] money for you
all right Paulie we got the [__]
Eagles and they're playing the Kansas
City Chiefs it's a rematch of last
year's Super Bowl they got crazy [__]
Eddie coaching the Eagles and then we
got the BTK killer coaching the Chiefs
we got a pop star up in the [__]
stands we got a [__]
guy with the Rocks original haircut at
quarterback crazy Eddie's Perfect Dude
Crazy Eddie I'm crazy Eddie and I'm
coaching the [__] Eagles I'm insane
and then the BTK killer I like burn
torture kill that's what he does to the
other team's game plan I like the Chiefs
to C to to win the game
you um or no I don't Jaylen Herz I they
got a lot [__] T got Patrick Mahomes
I I actually I do like to Chiefs I feel
like the Chiefs are kind of uh I'm not
talking about the Eagles here I just
feel like this is the time of year where
they start putting things
together um momes to throw
one yeah in a really douchy way and
they're like oh my god I've never seen
anybody throw a football like that
around the back it's like yeah it's a
[__] shovel pass all right so we'll
go that's how you throw a ball [__]
two-year-old like what are we doing here
Kelsey to catch one you want to go
Chiefs the whole way momes to throw one
Kelsey to catch one Chiefs to win by
three this way we don't have to worry
about I mean there not I don't think
Patrick's gonna run one
in I hope he doesn't because I hate the
way he runs he's gonna go for [__]
he's gonna go for Kelce with Taylor
Swift in the
crowd or is he
jealous nah he just had his third kid
he's good he's got three kids he's got
two girls and now he's got a little boy
who does who's got got three kids
Mahomes Taylor Swift no Mahomes he
keeping him in the piano pole Mahomes
all right all right I go
okay all right we're gonna take the
Chiefs [__] over under 45 and a half
Paul oh let's not do it dude let's no
let's not put ourselves in that box
again we almost got shout out to the
[__] Broncos kicker missing two extra
points so the under came in by
one 45 and a half is such a perfect
number for V it's such a perfect
number all right Chiefs Travis Kelce we
need we need one other thing we need one
other thing here well if Travis Kelsey
gets one then that means Mahomes throws
one well there you go so if Mahomes
throws one to Kelsey early in the game
we got two out of three and then we just
need a win by
three but if he
doesn't if he doesn't [__] this Paul we
got a little momentum here let's do it
Ms is goingon to throw in a Travis
Kelce all right he's going to do an
Endzone celebration longer than his
girlfriend's concert and I think the
Chiefs are gonna uh CH are gonna win
yeah yeah oh this is gonna be such a
hard game to watch because I would love
the Eagles to come in and shut up those
people I would the same way I would love
to see the Chiefs go in and just shut up
the eagle fans I don't know what it is
it's some about a Monday night I'm a bit
of a scrooge Grinch on Monday nights
Andrew thess is right Andrew themess
just said the odds are going to be small
on what we're picking we're basically
picking the best quarterback to throw a
touchdown to the best tight end and for
them to win at home on Monday night so
do you want to say that Mahomes gets two
touchdown passes I want to say something
Jaylen Herz is gonna do okay jaylen's
gonna throw one I think this is going to
be a back and forth Paul look at that
spread Vegas knows this going to be a
close game Jaylen hurts to throw one
Chiefs to cover Travis Kelce to get a
touchdown how about that how does how
does that make the odds look there
Andrew no no no we're going to do four
things we're going to do Jaylen Hertz to
throw one Ms to throw one Kelsey to
catch a touchdown Chiefs to cover yeah
and that'll make some odds yeah let's do
that let's do Jaylen to throw one
Mahomes to throw one Kelsey to catch one
and the [__] Chief's cover make some
people some money dude we got momentum
dude I could feel the vi it's it's we
have we have juice right now on the show
can we bet on whether or not the Eagles
coach is going to nod into the camera oh
dude what are the odds on that can we
get some odd we go zero odds on that oh
D when he takes it off that was one of
the funniest and [__] cringeworthy
things I ever
saw it was terrible I was nervous I was
going oh no is every [__] head coach
G to start doing that I hate that whole
thing are they just having fun they
having fun no they're not they're not
they're they're they're they're drawing
attention to
themselves you know
yeah I don't mind a an Endzone
celebration but the [__] when they have
like all the linemen and they start
doing Like A Chorus Line or acting like
they're all rowing a boat or something
it's like do you guys actually rehearse
that in the locker room it's terrible
yeah it is thank you it's terrible it's
like most things it starts off it's a
good idea and then it goes too far like
those Police Academy movies it was a
fantastic idea did we need nine of
them yeah I know what you mean when they
I like how priv hooks had to keep trying
to fight that was the most accurate
thing would she be all quiet and in the
end she'd be like don't move dirt bag
and then the next movie she started
again she was mousy again she had the
exact same story arc through all nine of
them but what I loved about it was
that's how life is you don't just decide
to make a change and then you change you
got to work at it yeah that'd be funny
if in the ninth one she was just a
[__] Psy from the beginning the [__]
did you say to me oh you finally pushed
through the wall yes I
did yeah they uh police academy kind of
jumped the shark after they went to
Miami they were like at a
pool well first they were in training
and then they went out to the forest and
then somehow retroactively they had one
back in
training Police Academy back in training
it's like what the [__] are they back
there for oh that's so funny remember
when tackleberry put a gun he put a 44
to a shark's nose and he goes move it
move the shark turned around and swam
over you look at that now it's like the
dumbest thing ever I love tackleberry no
tackleberry was great but tackleberry
high tower yeah private hooks the chick
with the big tits oh I mean you I had to
have one of those every 80s movies yeah
had him hanging out the whole [__]
time Bobcat gowe was in it
yeah and so what his name what's his
name the kid who did the sound effects
he's a comedian oh Michael Winslow
Michael Winslow who did all the sound
effects he was the guy who was making
all the noises and then you had Steve
Gutenberg as uh Mahoney yeah was
Cannonball Run at the police academy um
all right Paul I gotta get ready to go
to Vegas I gotta go to Vegas Paul oh
speaking I'm going to Vegas hey man you
got to take your luck over to the crabs
table uh you know what's funny they were
playing craps last night on Cojack nice
on get on the get channel great
Entertainment
Television and you know what's funny is
when I record it I get the end of the
Rockford files and at the end of Cojack
Quincy
starts I can never get into Quincy how
many uh how many seasons of cojak were
there five five nice so uh they're
running they just did the first episode
one of season 5 and it's funny his
[__] callers are out to hear like as
the seasons go they get like bigger and
bigger so now this is right around
Saturday Night Fever oh that's great his
his pant legs are starting to flare out
but he keeps the three-piece suits Telly
looks sharp dude yeah he's KY looks
sharp and for no reason he's always
[__] he's talking to like like
criminals other cops and what if they're
female he's at least pecking them on the
cheek good looking Greek kid man you
know Paul I want to reboot that I want
to reboot it with you playing Telly
seales and Tony V playing that other cop
he's got Tony V here dude let's do it
and then I'll play uh Bobby what's his
face Who falls in love with the [__]
chick dude I would [__] I would take
that so seriously and Crush that role
I'm dead serious um all right everybody
that's the uh that's the show he drives
a four-door sedan Paul it's right up
your [__] alley uh all right that's
the show everyone that's the show
everybody enjoy the Monday night special
and
remember Jaylen Herz to throw one
Patrick Mahomes to throw one Travis
Kelce to catch one the Chiefs win by a
field goal at home on Monday night I
think all those things should happen I
hope you guys um uh enjoy it bet
responsibly but win a little bit of
Christmas money there you go there you
go $10 in the account when you download
the app you get back up to 200 in bets
regardless of the outcome of your first
bet use our bonus code bur 200 B rr2 100
bet responsibly enjoy the games this
week and we will see you next week on
the anything better podcast I didn't
even see these comments here I just saw
Kyler Murray then it says 49ers are
healthy uh oh all right we'll see what
happens Paul no that was during the
picks when we asked what any injury
reports I know but I'm just saying okay
I didn't see that and I took Tampa Bay
and I'm sticking with it all right
that's it we'll see you guys later